what are your thoughts
i'd be curious you're a good person to
ask which is uh
penn rose's roger penrose's work on
consciousness
saying that there you know there is some
with axons and so on there might be some
biological places where quantum
mechanics can come into play
and through that create consciousness
somehow yeah
okay well um uh familiar with his work
of course
you know i read penrose's books as a
teenager they had a huge
impact on me uh uh five or six years ago
i had the privilege to actually talk
these things over with penrose you know
at some length at a conference in
minnesota
and uh you know he is uh uh you know an
amazing
uh personality i admire the fact that he
was
even raising such uh audacious questions
at all
uh but you know to to to answer your
question i think the first thing we need
to
get clear on is that he is not merely
saying that quantum mechanics is
relevant to consciousness
right that would be like um you know
that would be tame
compared to what he is saying right he
is saying that
you know even quantum mechanics is not
good enough right if because if
supposing for example that the brain
were a quantum computer
maybe that's still a computer you know
in fact a quantum computer can be
simulated by an ordinary computer it
might merely need exponentially more
time in order to do so
right so that's simply not good enough
for him okay so what he wants
is for the brain to be a quantum
gravitational computer
or or uh uh he wants the brain to be
exploiting
as yet unknown laws of quantum gravity
okay which would which would be
uncomputable
that's the key point okay yes yes that
would be literally
uncomputable and i've asked him you know
to clarify this but
uncomputable even if you had an oracle
for the halting problem
or you know and and or you know as high
up as you want to go
and the sort of high the usual hierarchy
of uncomputability
he wants to go beyond all of that okay
so
so you know just to be clear like you
know if we're keeping count of how many
speculations
you know there's probably like at least
five or six of them right
there's first of all that there is some
quantum gravity theory that would
involve this kind of uncomputability
right most people who study quantum
gravity would not agree with that they
would say that
what we've learned you know what little
we know about quantum gravity from the
this ads cft correspondence for example
has been very much consistent with the
broad idea of nature being computable
right um but uh but all right but but
supposing that he's right about that
then you know
what most physicists would say is that
whatever
new phenomena there are in quantum
gravity you know they might be relevant
at the singularities of black holes they
might be relevant at the big bang
uh they are plainly not relevant to
something like the brain
you know that is operating at ordinary
temperatures
you know with ordinary chemistry
and you know the the the physics
underlying the brain they would say that
we have you know the fundamental physics
of the brain they would say that we've
pretty much completely known for for
generations now
right uh because you know quantum field
theory
lets us sort of parametrize our
ignorance
right i mean sean carroll has made this
case and you know in great detail right
that sort of whatever new effects are
coming from quantum gravity
you know they are sort of screened off
by quantum field theory right and this
is
this bring you know brings us to the
whole idea of effective theories right
but that
like we have you know that in like in
the standard model of elementary
particles
right we have a quantum field theory
that seems totally adequate for all of
the terrestrial phenomena
right the only things that it doesn't
you know explain
are well first of all you know the
details of gravity
if you were to probe it like at at a uh
you know extremes of you know
curvature or at like incredibly small
distances
it doesn't explain dark matter it
doesn't explain black hole singularities
right but these are all very exotic
things very you know far removed from
our life on earth
right so for penrose to be right he
needs
you know these phenomena to somehow
affect the brain he needs the brain to
contain
antenna that are sensitive to the black
hole
to this as yet unknown physics right and
then he needs
a modification of quantum mechanics okay
so he needs
quantum mechanics to actually be wrong
okay he needs
uh uh what what he wants is what he
calls an objective reduction mechanism
or
an objective collapse so this is the
idea that once quantum states
get large enough then they somehow
spontaneously collapse right that uh uh
um you know and and this is an idea that
lots of people have explored
uh you know there's uh something called
the grw
proposal that uh tries to uh you know
say something along those lines you know
these are theories that actually make
testable predictions
right which is a nice feature that they
have but you know the very fact that
they're testable may mean that in the
uh you know in the in the coming decades
we may well be able to test these
theories and show that they're
they're wrong right uh you know we may
be able to test some of penrose's ideas
if not not his ideas about consciousness
but at least his ideas that about an
objective
collapse of quantum states right and
people have actually
like dick baumeister have actually been
working to try to do these experiments
they haven't been able to do it yet to
test penrose's proposal
okay but penrose would need more than
just an objective collapse of quantum
states
which would already be the biggest
development in physics for a century
since quantum mechanics itself okay he
would need
for consciousness to somehow be able to
influence
the direction of the collapse so that it
wouldn't be completely random
but that you know your dispositions
would somehow influence the quantum
state
to collapse more likely this way or that
way
okay finally penrose you know says that
all of this has to be true
because of an argument that he makes
based on girdle's incompleteness theorem
okay right now like i would say the
overwhelming majority of computer
scientists
and mathematicians who have thought
about this
i don't think that girdles and
completeness theorem can do what he
needs it to do
here right i don't think that that
argument is sound okay
but that is you know that is sort of the
tower that you have to ascend to if
you're going to go where penrose goes
and the
intuition uses with uh yeah the
completeness theorem is that basically
that there's important stuff that's not
computable
it's not just that because i mean
everyone agrees that there are problems
that are uncomputable right that's a
mathematical theorem
right that but what penrose wants to say
is that
uh uh you know the um you know for
example there are statements
uh you know for you know given any uh
formal system you know for doing math
right there will be true statements of
arithmetic
that that formal system you know if it's
adequate for math at all if it's
consistent and so on will not be able to
prove
a famous example being the statement
that that system itself is consistent
right no you know good formal system can
actually prove its own consistency
that can only be done from a stronger
formal system
which then can't prove its own
consistency and so on forever
okay that's gurdle's theorem but now why
is that relevant
to uh consciousness right uh uh
well you know i mean i mean the idea
that it might have something to do with
consciousness as an old one
girdle himself apparently thought that
it was really um you know
uh lucas uh uh uh um
um thought so i think in the 60s and
penrose is really just you know sort of
updating what what
uh uh what what they and others had said
i mean you know the idea that girdle's
theorem
could have something to do with
consciousness was you know um
in in 1950 when alan turing wrote his
article
uh about the touring test he already you
know
was writing about that as like an old
and well-known idea and as one that he
was as a wrong one that he wanted to
dispense with
right okay but the basic problem with
this idea is you know penrose wants to
say
that and and all of his predecessors
your you know want to say
that you know even though you know this
given formal system
cannot prove uh its own consistency
we as humans sort of looking at it from
the outside
can just somehow see its consistency
right
and the you know the rejoinder to that
you know from the very beginning has
been well can we really
yeah i mean maybe or maybe maybe you
know maybe maybe he
penrose can but you know can the rest of
us right
uh and you know i i noticed that that um
you know i i mean it is perfectly
plausible to imagine a computer
that could say you know it would not be
limited to working within a single
formal system
right they could say i am now going to
adopt the hypothesis
that this that my formal system is
consistent right and i'm now going to
see what can be done from that stronger
vantage point and
and so on and you know when i'm going to
add new axioms to my system
totally plausible there's absolutely
girdle's theorem has nothing to say
about against an ai that could
repeatedly add new axioms
all it says is that there is no absolute
guarantee
that when the ai adds new axioms that it
will always be right
right okay and you know and that's of
course the point that penrose pounces on
but the reply is obvious and you know
it's one that that alan turing made 70
years ago
name we we don't have an absolute
guarantee that we're right when we add a
new axiom
right we never have and plausibly we
never will
you